also ich würd vorschlagen wie
kontrahieren jeweils den musculus
molekulares ortes und führen die ganze
sache okay
[Musik]
menschliche lippen sind ziemlich
auffällig wie man sie mit denen unserer
tierischen freunde vergleicht erstens
sind sie ziemlich nach außen gestülpt
und zweitens haben wir eine klare grenze
zwischen der normalen haut und der
lippenhaut die auch für million dollar
genannt wird familien es englisch führt
zehn low rot und auch wenn unsere lippen
nicht zwingend strahle droht sind so
hielt sich ihre farbe doch meistens vom
rest des gesichts ab und so ist es
wahrscheinlich auch kein zufall dass wir
uns unsere lippen gerne rot anmalen denn
auch im tierreich sind rote körperteile
wie liebt und potenzielle partner
anzulocken
nur weil wir unsere auffälligen lippen
dazu benutzten uns zu küssen
heißt es nicht dass uns küssen angeboren
ist es gibt in der tat kulturen die
nicht küssen und die uns wahrscheinlich
ziemlich zu entscheiden also habe ich
das jetzt richtig verstand ihre münder
und zungen an einander küssen es
wissenschaftlich hoch interessant viele
motto logi und zum beispiel die
wissenschaft des küsten hey baby an dir
würde ich gerne viele matte logische
studien durchführen doch vor allem der
ursprung des küssens beschäftigte
forscher ich stelle euch heute drei
mögliche antworten vor auf die frage
warum küssen küssen kommt vom still
manche sagen man braucht etwa 40 muskeln
beim küssen andere sagen es in sogar 140
koch wahrscheinlich auf den kuss an
sagen wir sind relativ viele muskeln und
immerhin verbrennt man beim küssen etwa
drei bis sieben kalorien brooks in der
regel fängt ein kuss aber mit den lippen
spitzen angst dass der muskel
orbicularis ortes zusammen gezogen wird
der serie muskel mit denen sich babys
auch an der mutterbrust festsaugen
übrigens in welche richtung dreht ihr
eigentlich euren kopf beim küssen die
mehrheit und zwar etwa zwei drittel der
menschen drehen beim küssen ihren kopf
nach rechts
das könnte vielleicht daran liegen dass
etwa 80 prozent der mitte ihre babys
andere
brustschild es könnte also sein dass wir
eine rechts dreh schon als baby
verinnerlichen 21 küssen kommt vom
füttern wenn man so darüber nachdenkt
ist küssen eigentlich ziemlich eklig man
wird ja auch keinen speicher von jemand
anderem trinken aber speicher direkt von
null zum und auszutauschen das finden
wir super
noch wichtiger ist allerdings die
theorie dass küssen vom mund zu mund
füttern stand viele vögel oder auch
schimpansen füttern ihre babys von mund
zu mund von viele forscher glauben dass
küssen eine art erfindung der mitte der
uhrzeit ist die ihren kleinen zahllosen
babys das essen zu kaufen um es dann
über den gespitztem mund einzuflößen
dafür auch damals kein baby beim
gläschen oder pürierstab drittens küssen
kommt zum riechen war ihr schon mal in
der situation dass ihr eine person mehr
attraktiv findet aber dann nach dem
ersten kuss nicht mehr so vielleicht
könntet ihr euch in der tat nicht wie
viele pheromone das sind quasi duft
botenstoffe werden an unseren
nasenflügel gebildet und abgesondert so
dass es sich lohnen könnte die nasen
näher zusammen zu stecken
es gibt sehr viele sehr interessante
studien dazu wie der geruch eines
menschen mit seiner attraktivität
zusammenhängt dazu könnt ihr mal ganzes
video machen jedenfalls viele forscher
glauben dass der kuss eine art aus
checken ist ob jemand als potenzieller
partner in frage kommt indem man seinen
speichel kostet oder sein geruch atmet
also wenn ihr gerade niemanden zum
knutschen habt und neidisch auf
knutschende paare seit dann denkt doch
nächstes mal einfach all for gekauftes
essen dann sieht das ganze schon direkt
weniger spaßig aus schön schlau
das war teil 1 von warum küssen wir in
teil zwei wird es darum gehen was küssen
eigentlich genau mit unserem körper
anstellt und bauen wir es so toll finden
hat eine schöne und valentinswoche mit
oder ohne küssen ich hoffe jedenfalls
dass ich euch das küssen nicht allzusehr
verdorben habe bis zum nächsten mal